I like to believe that there's goodness
and all of us some may have more than
others some may have more opportunity to
display it than others do and some are
given the opportunity but however never
grasped it I've known my friend Robyn
Russell for many years and through those
years I have seen her use every
opportunity to show her goodness her
charity and her deep concern for others
friends relatives and strangers and when
I was told that she was getting the Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award I didn't
wait for the Academy to call me I called
Howard Koch she's a friend of mine who's
brought great credit to our industry
through these years for instance the
first thing Roz did when she arrived in
Hollywood was to unpack her makeup kit
and drive over to Boyle Heights
to the Jewish Home for the Aged where
she read chatted and ate with the folks
over there she became a founder of the
league for crippled children with the
orthopedic hospital here in Los Angeles
and that led her to five years of
fundraising for her friend sister Kenton
and then came a chairmanship that
lighthouse for the blind the National
Arthritis Foundation Catholic Charities
in New York Children's Services in
Connecticut and tornado victims and
Kansas and always the motion picture
television and Relief Fund her war
activities were late Legion she was a
front one of the founders of the USO and
Los Angeles the first actress to
entertain in the camps and believe it or
not in 1942 she gave a Christmas party
for two armored divisions a mere 36,000
guys she has been nominated four times
an Academy Award and knowing Roz as I do
she would rather have this one than the
other four they have been and will be
others who deserve this award as much as
rise but no one will ever deserve it
more ladies and gentlemen
mrs. Roslyn Russell brisson
because we go away it seems like we
stood this way before but thank you dear
your wonderful friend and of course I am
profoundly grateful to the governors of
the Academy I was listening to his words
back there
Frank and I thought for a minute someone
out there I think I was kind of special
far from it you know the people of this
of this nation I have a golden tradition
of taking care of each other and across
America right now there are men and
women countless numbers of them young
and old who are giving of themselves to
hospitals to orphanages to drug clinics
to youth and even possibly watching a
little child take her first steps after
being crippled as I have watched so the
only unique thing about me tonight is
that I'm I'm here with this knowing that
it belongs to so many others I would
also like to tell you that I have been
the victim of this kindness and I want
to thank each and every one of them and
all the letters that were sent to me
over the years for all they did for me
while I was not quite well thank you
you